und ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich
ingrid hartges hauptgeschäftsführerin
des deutschen hotel und
gaststättenverbands frau hartges sie
haben in den letzten wochen monaten
immer wieder gesagt dass ihre branche
planungssicherheit und eine
zukunftsperspektive benötigt gibt ihnen
die politik nun beides
ja also das in der tat das wichtigste
was jetzt hergestellt werden muss
planungssicherheit es muss unter allen
umständen ein erneuter lockdown
verhindert werden es ist natürlich so
dass im moment die unterschiedlichen
regelungswerk in den bundesländern auch
die debatte im bundestag das schafft
natürlich alles keine sicherheit sondern
eher verunsicherung es sind viele offene
rechtsfragen weiterhin da was denken sie
denn über dieses optionsmodell in
hamburg wie viele in ihrer branche
werden diese option denn wirklich nutzen
das ist derzeit völlig offen
als wir warten ja auch noch auf den
wortlaut der verordnung die reaktionen
sind sehr geteilt darauf also die einen
sagen das ist eine lösung für meinen
betrieb andere lehnen das ab weil sie
das gefühl haben dass hier eine
diskussion auf dem rücken der
gastronomie stattfindet mit den
ungeimpften die eben dann keinen zugang
mehr zu diesen betrieben haben also das
echo wie gesagt ist sehr geteilt
insgesamt müssen wir bundesweit sagen 3g
ja ist definitiv besser wie wenn wieder
das risiko besteht dass wir geschlossen
werden und zweig als solches sagt mit
dem rahmen des hausrechts hätte ja jeder
unternehmer schon die möglichkeit zweig
einzuführen wie es auch einige für
oktober angekündigt haben der kleine
charme des hamburger modells ist das per
verordnung gesagt wird wenn zweig
eingeführt wird wird der unternehmer
dann von den corona schutzmaßnahmen wie
abstandsgebot etc entlastet kann also
die kapazitäten ausschöpfen da wird also
ein anreiz gesetzt ja inwieweit besteht
dadurch dann vielleicht auch ein
wirtschaftlicher zwang sich für 2g zu
entscheiden also zusätzlich endlich
wieder rentiert zu öffnen
also ich glaube wir müssen jetzt erst
einmal sorgfältig schauen wie sieht der
verordnungstext aus spätestens morgen
wird er wohl veröffentlicht weil ab
samstag soll die regelung gelten wir
müssen dann sehen wie viele unternehmer
schließen sich dem modell an welche
erfahrungen machen sie damit also ich
glaube das ist derzeit noch verfrüht
fakt ist es hängt sehr stark vom
betriebstyp ab und vom gästekreis also
wenn ich überwiegend bester gäste habe
über 50 über 60 die mehrheitlich geimpft
sind dann ist es vielleicht weniger ein
problem gerade auch in kleineren
restaurants und cafés wenn ich einen
großen betrieb habe auch viele junge
menschen ansprechen die noch nicht
geimpft sind dann wird sich der
unternehmer sicherlich für 3g
entscheiden auch die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter der einrichtungen im
zweig modell müssen ja dann geimpft oder
genesen sein halten sie das für
vernünftig oder könnte es da auch
schwierig werden genug personal zu
finden da gibt's ja offenbar ohnehin
probleme
also die ganze debatte ist in der tat
eine situation wo wir den größten
fachkräftemangel aller zeiten tritt
quasi haben
natürlich nicht unbedingt hilfreich als
waren mir viele offene rechtsfragen
rechtlich ist es heute so dass der
arbeitgeber kein recht hat nachdem im
status der mitarbeiter zu fragen er kann
nur tests
anordnen dort wo auch in der
landesverordnung eine testpflicht
vorgesehen ist also dass es auch eine
schwierige situation es gibt arbeitgeber
die sagen es möchte gerne die
ungeimpften mitarbeiter jeden tag jeden
zweiten tag testen lassen kann er eben
nicht nur da wo das per verordnung
geregelt ist also wir haben da im moment
für unsere unternehmer keine einfache
situation vor allen dingen befürchten
wir natürlich auch nicht wenige konflikt
geneigte gespräche im restaurant eingang
wie sind denn da die reaktionen der
gäste aktuell auf der aktuellen corona
maßnahmen wie groß ist da die akzeptanz
noch
also ich glaube mit 3g hat man hier am
10 august eine entscheidung getroffen in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sie wird mehrheitlich begrüsst
und natürlich kann sie im einzelfall mal
mit umsatzeinbußen verbunden sein da wo
ich denn weniger spontan besucher
bekomme sie ist natürlich aufwendiger
ich muss jemanden abstellen der das
alles kontrolliert am eingang aber
insgesamt ist 3g derzeit glaube ich die
beste lösung und auch eine
verhältnismäßige lösung aber wir stelle
ich mir das dann
beispielhaft im hotel vorbei dem 3g
modell da muss man unterscheiden
zwischen geimpften getestete und
genesenen und wenn der gast länger
bleibt dann muss man den ja immer wieder
darauf hinweisen durch brauchen neues
testergebnis wie aufwändig ist das und
kann das geleistet werden also wir haben
damit ja schon erfahrungen gehabt wir
sind ja im mai geöffnet worden mit 3g
also sowohl in der hotellerie wie auch
in der innen gastronomie konnte der
zugang ja nur gewährleistet werden eben
mit dem 3gs und von daher gibt es da
erfahrungen der vorteil ist dass heute
deutlich mehr menschen mehr gäste
geimpft sind oder genesen sind und also
ich glaube das ist kein problem das
haben die betriebe immer juni
bewerkstelligt und wie gesagt das gilt
im übrigen auch nicht überall als in
mecklenburg vorpommern nur bei anreise
negativ test und dann keine folge test
in anderen bundesländern alle drei tage
muss im hotel dann getestet werden aber
ich glaube da sind alle gewohnt mit
damit umzugehen also das ist nicht das
größte problem sondern wie gesagt wir
müssen insgesamt müssen wir die pandemie
in den griff bekommen und zur normalität
wieder zurückkommen und mehr ermöglichen
ich glaube das muss die politik auf der
agenda haben sie muss überfällig endlich
hier kriterien zur qualifizierten
beurteilung der infektions lage
entwickeln das ist sie im 18 monat der
pandemie schuldig geblieben es muss
zwingend die impfquote die
hospitalisierung rate berücksichtigt
werden neben dem incidents wert und der
wird ja jetzt auch hoffentlich endlich
mal konkretes vorgelegt werden in den
nächsten tagen ja das ist ja geplant ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei jenen
frau hat es gern gesehen schönen tag
noch auf wieder hin